hello hello we back in a bit of wheat
bagging on that yeah how you doing here
a long time I know it's been since last
week last week we did the fan mail
mailbag my fourth right it's been a good
week off I enjoyed it
oh man that was some important people
felt good doing your thing I felt like
July 4th lasted a full week this year
middle yeah it was non-stop I feel like
I've intoxicated my body more in this
past week than I have in a long long
time being able to spend July 4th at big
Phil's house was truly a great time
thanks thank you my god my girlfriend
enum came it was a lot of fun and I
think that I know I would like to invest
in your nephew Patrick Patrick you like
Patrick huh
I've never seen a kid with hand-eye
coordination this kid is to their nerve
they're gonna make it work with him he
hit 17 wiffle ball bat lasers in a row
and like grown men were like and missing
and he was like no you okay what are you
talking about
yeah I mean it looked like you broke a
rib on your first swing of the night
last the other day your dad referred to
me as the Aaron judge of all some good
ones but you call me the hammer
so hard to impress everybody in the
first one he might hit a home run and he
swang and he grunted when he got done I
really did I was like damn I hope he
didn't pull a muscle but then he had
some bombs the left center had the
biggest hits of the night but good all
good
you definitely did you have a seven
seven I hit the three run RBI to win the
game the game the fact that you can
remember that yes goes to our
relationship for me it's a blur and I
just remember look at your little nephew
that's good right
Phil was hilarious I love feels so much
can you tell about my firework show it
didn't like that your fireworks are
great you're a really good fourth of
July dad yeah you Lea little Mew walked
out of the way your family is great cuz
everything it looked whenever is a
downbeat someone's like good job
Christopher but I Kyle came over and
your son was not prepared he wasn't like
that Stewart he yeah Kyle yes the the
Shanahan's were in town this weekend
favorite coach Kyle
which Kyle Shanahan Kyle's sister lives
close to me in Connecticut and Kyle's
sister crystal is her name
went to Texas with us so I mean she's a
great friend family affair family affair
Kyle comes usually every other summer to
come up this way to visit her and yeah
so he's coming over the house
Tuesday afternoon he's ahead we're gonna
stop by around three o'clock cool blah
blah you know I yell upstairs my little
boys play at fortnight hey Phillip you
know kya coach Shanahan and his kids are
gonna come over in a little bit okay so
whatever Kyle comes in the door here
comes all the sudden Phillip running
down the stairs hi Carter that's yeah
the famous son of yeah Lil Wayne and my
son's wearing a russell wilson Jersey
and Kyle looks at me like has a smile on
his face he goes oh and it's the the
bright green Russell Wilson alternate oh
cool he goes cool Jersey cool Jersey
Phillip I mean it's only our
arch-nemesis we kind of all just
laughter like Phillip saying Phil was
like oh oh sorry sorry I don't have a
49ers Jersey can you get me one and
which one is it gonna go I think he's
gonna go Jimmy G I think it's got Jimmy
G Q yeah I spent the weekend in Vegas
Bleacher Report doing a bunch of BR jump
off stuff out there for summer league
one thing Vegas football is gonna be
amazing
right I'm I can already tell if I was
the Vegas you can't do this so anyone
that's listening in Vegas think about
the team I would not sell a lot of
season tickets I would just save them
for the road team to come because man a
weekend in Vegas with a game on Sunday
it's it's the perfect road trip for a
good football and you're gonna be stupid
and you're already willing to spend
money at that point and you're probably
intoxicated being in Vegas yes yeah it's
gonna lead to a lot of bad decisions of
scalping tickets still oh I think it's
gonna be awesome no I just think Vegas
football will be great but three things
happen this weekend that I really really
enjoyed my three favorite things yeah
one of them was first day I got there I
was in the pool with Lance fresh and we
convinced a group of people that I was
an Orlando Magic player that's always
the best people look at Lance and
they're like I don't you look and then
so if you're next to the guy that looks
they think that you're somebody so I was
a new point guard for the magic a lot of
fun move the magic suck exactly that's
why you got to there was a big bleacher
report party at a haka I don't realize
how skinny basketball players are like
you're I'm usually a giant in basketball
as far as thickness yes yes like her
legs are shockingly thin right they're
very fat man you realize that really
athletic people have really tiny cats
right like I like I have a big cap
people like real athletes like Patrick
Peterson's calf muscles probably like
that I think of Michael Jordan it's a
little fist on the top of the leg right
behind their kneecap there and they're
freakishly tall yes like walking around
a Vegas casino you're like I don't know
who that is but you're six it's unreal
it really is we had a party at Hakkasan
and little john was deejaying yeah and
he was like major bar yeah yeah it was
like great but then at one point it was
a truly a seminal moment for me he
explained from the window to the wall
yeah like he sweat drops down mine yes
but he gave a dissertation he goes now
can everyone point to the window yeah
and now can it and I was like this is
the moment I've always wanted with a
little John is a is a real serious
explanation of from the window to the
wall right number one moment though for
me so wait what is it you didn't explain
anything you just said he pointed at a
window and I just enjoyed the process of
explaining it okay yeah it was a little
John so he likes to have sex by the
window I think brings the girl over to I
don't know okay I thought you're gonna
give me something good there James no he
was like my creative process I typically
go to England and have a little scone
and then I say what do I want to talk
about Little John doesn't think Little
John plays techno I didn't know that
really last thing the next night were at
Omni F for bleacher report and I walk up
to the line and the guys checking ID and
I usually don't like the ID tecar he's
always like the most disgruntled person
ever and this guy looked at my ID and
without breaking stride goes i watch her
podcast all the time and I go for real
he goes yes we're Sims I was like oh
he's at home
and I was like can I can I have a stand
he's like oh yeah steal your license and
then when I went up there this other guy
came up and he goes mr. luff go come
with me and I was like nobody [ __ ]
knows that yeah and he pulls me over he
goes big fan of the podcast big Niners
so those two guys I forget their names
and I apologize the guy's helping us out
at Omni you guys are [ __ ] awesome
Raiders fan it's good Raiders fan the
brand is strong in Vegas so when we do
our live show in Vegas yeah I have that
on the calendar I'll tell you the date
please do well let's wait to the Raiders
move there hopefully bleacher report I
still want us then and we'll do a few
podcast there and hopefully Gruden will
still be employed hopefully and he'll
give us a little like just percentage of
his 10 years 100 million and we'll
gamble and have him on the bun guy
Gruden Gamble's no he's not like a
blackjack guy a roulette guy I think so
I think he would maybe be the kind of
like friendly wagers on the golf course
okay I don't know any coaches that I can
think of and I'm being dead serious here
that really wager anything on sports
like maybe funny things out sports what
about like blackjack and stuff like that
yeah I don't even oh yeah don't do that
but I don't think it's like I don't know
anybody that's obsessed with it would
have the worst poker face ever
right cuz Gruder would look at his cards
and his eyebrows would be going like all
over the place he'd be scouring like
don't you think he'd be better yes he
haven't have a horrible poker face or no
he could have a good poker face though
too because he can be like really like
[ __ ] happy and still have a Chucky
face on - yeah I know a few assistant
coaches yeah MBA coaches that I could
say like oh through my years like when
they had time off they were gonna find
their way to the craps table or
something like that
but head coaches I never knew gambler
I'm really not
you like poker I do like poker I would
said to get the thing I gamble on more
than anything is backgammon which you've
heard me do that's a dime 26,000 and the
whole not really shouldn't count I mean
the first game we ever played I never
even learned the game we'd bet a hundred
dollars and he like tripled me
and I'm like $400 right when I started
talking [ __ ] dear dad on July 4th about
cornhole yeah I've never seen him get
more excited you think you're pretty
good let me go get the boards and I like
he like stopped barbecuing to go beat my
ass and they don't have the board's no
dirty Diane yeah she throws a little
dirty yes she's gonna that's what she
does he's got a rule he's unbelievable
um I do just made me think maybe we
should do like a Sims and left go
backgammon Invitational or or a poker
tournament these are all things I'm
thinking about we're growing this one
goes getting big backgammon is a lot of
fun it's fun to gamble on that's why I'd
say there's really quick - we have a lot
of cool [ __ ] in the work we're gonna be
able to YouTube show starting like right
before the first week of the NFL season
and when that happens of all the things
that we've asked you to support that's
the number one thing that we want you
guys to support because I think that's
the next evolution of what we're doing
is a reactionary more detailed video
show with NFL players yes so when that
happens you will know but that's what I
really want and everybody on the reddit
our reddit page apparently has already
created two fantasy football leagues
because there was too much demand for
the first fantasy football league also -
you guys I'm gonna be shouting you guys
out during the year if someone gets
their ass kicked or someone has like the
team of the century will bring it up
scout the league out a little bit of our
two cents every now and then cuz you
talking fantasy football's of me oh it's
amazing I I'm all for talking fantasy
football just give you the realistic
nature of it I don't know exactly all
the rules of fantasy but I'll do my best
to tell you the real stuff speaking of
Vegas odds I found this interesting bet
DSi sports book has the Jaguars
over/under win at how many game Sims
what do you think it is ooh what should
it be I'm gonna say it's nine it's eight
mmm felt a little low to me III hear you
but when we were talking the other day
you kind of you're kind of down the
Jackson I'm not down on the Jags
I said doubt oh okay yeah I'm not down
on him I wasn't trying to be a jerk to
you there I'm just saying like the Jags
are a team that scared me they're a team
that I look at and go if the team's I
feel like through my history that I look
at that can have these little downfalls
like they would be one of those teams
okay they're still
extremely talented they've made
improvements on their roster I mean to
get Norwell for that running game
DJ shark cos yes I'm tearing it up I've
been told he there they got light they
got one of the best receivers in the
draft at the end of the second round I
mean the 6-3 guy that's 190 that ran the
fastest forty on offense is tearing it
up it's a shocker scouted by Tom
Coughlin who is an expert in scouting
receivers so they're I mean they got the
tape and Brian guy in the first run
that's unbelievable but I just look at
it like this there's still questions
about that offense right thanks
blackboard course they of course and I
and the way they play football games are
it's tight and close physical football
games anyway so a lot of those games we
saw last year they came dry I could just
see you don't get off to the right start
and their first three games this year
would scare me a little bit schedules
and say the matchups are not great for
them the Giants are a team that can go
we can just stand in there physically
with you and play ugly football and hope
it don't breaks one or eel I'll be
clutching the last drive but we'll go
down and kick a field goal and beaches
17 to 13 right the Patriots the next
week that would scare me a course it's
the [ __ ] Patriots we know that even
the Tennessee Titans that's gonna be a
different so they're just one of those
teams where I go they're one of the best
football teams in the sport no doubt
about that I don't but the way they play
I think could lead them to some cheap
losses they're not gonna trick anybody
or catch anybody by surprise this year I
still think they're a playoff team but
they're gonna be like I think this year
like a nine and seven playoff team that
gets in and then we go oh [ __ ] watch out
for the Jag I was surprised because the
the sports book also projected the
Texans as the favorite to win the south
Wow um the only one I guess on the Titan
side like I feel really good about the
Titans this year I'm getting more and
more cocky like they have the best
offensive line of all the team yeah
they have Matt Lafleur at OC who's been
picking up stuff from Shanahan McVeigh
you got Vrabel down on the defensive
side they already went to the playoffs
last year yeah I like Derek Henry and
Dion Lewis I know like some of their why
receive like I I like Malcom Butler and
your guy the other corner from USC
Torrey Jackson I know Kevin Byers and
ryankevin by yard I mean yes
they're stacked right Malcolm Butler
yeah they got our guy Harold Landry got
a second round jerel case you still
there hexans I think people are looking
at it and going if they get DeSean yeah
who in that span was incredible and JJ
mann-whitney merciless and he just got
Erica Colvin the corner from
Jacksonville and they just got high
battery right yeah like I can see it but
I think that that's one of the most
fascinating conversations in the sport
and then those three teams and then who
the hell knows it's got about Andrew
Luck right because I look at the Colts
and go you know that they had halftime
leads and like six of their last nine
games I know and I would expect them to
be better and I course I'm hoping Andrew
Luck will be playing so yeah that
divisions wide open if you know crazy
and that's those are all reasons though
where I go Jacksonville can maybe just
slip a hair this year I guess it would
just be might use looks like anytime you
exceed expectations and you finally
break through right you're going to feel
yourself a little bit definitely on you
deserves to feel themselves this was a
stat that was put on there by your
friend Mike Florio Floria your other
host yeah on profile planner work wife
yeah no just the other guy he's the
other guy he posted this and I think it
needs to be shared Aaron Rodgers has 78
interceptions in his NFL career that is
1.6 percent of his passes and he threw
three of them in a game where he came
back and he shouldn't even been playing
what killed was the Carolina Panthers
game the last game even Bri came back
right he played in the game where he
probably shouldn't have been play and he
came back to save the day for the Green
Bay Packers he threw three of those
interceptions in that game he's only
thrown three interception game I believe
that was his only one of the career Wow
so but sorry the 1.6% is the lowest for
any quarterback in NFL history and I've
always wondered the whole like if I was
a Packers fan I don't know if I would
like farver Rodgers more that that to me
is one of the hardest debates as a fan
because Favre is more than just a
statistical guy yes with Favre
the reason it's great to argue for Favre
is you can go throw the statistics out
of the way let's just talk like he's a
gun scare about staff right but here's
the perspective Rodgers career-high in
interceptions for a season is 13
his first season as the starter if
rogers plays until he's 50 and throws 14
interceptions every single year so it's
like 16 more years he will still have
fewer career interceptions than brett
favre still rodgers you're the greatest
I've ever seen and it's because of [ __ ]
like this we're reading I mean okay
Brett Favre's the ultimate gunslinger
yes Aaron Rodgers really is every bit
the gunslinger Brett Favre is he's every
bit I mean come on we all watch Aaron
Rodgers and we go
oh it's Aaron Rodgers coming to town son
even the Green Bay Packers and Rodgers
coming to town to play your team yeah
and can he dance around and make
everybody miss and just whistling past
people's missiles all over the field I
watched that throw against Dallas to win
that game it was a rising line drive
that's over the corners head you me and
then of course after the game you have a
guy like Jason Garrett who's been around
the NFL for 30-something years and his
dad 30 years before that go know Aaron
Rodgers gonna be one of the three
greatest ever to lice lace up cleats
remember yeah so again I know I'm I love
Aaron Rodgers a lot of people do in
there in the NFL and it is things like
this because again as we talked about
just with our man Seahawk Scout yeah
shut the Seahawks up see how Scott see
how Seahawks scout the the the offense
that the Green Bay Packers run is like
the plays and stuff that Kyle shinny and
Shawn McVeigh and Josh McDaniels put in
the first two days of training camp and
they go hey this is just basic for
offense will probably only call these
plays like twice the whole year yeah but
it just get us going right and that's
the meat and potatoes Aaron Rodgers
offense that's what's unbelievable about
it I mean I don't know what to say he's
what I got it in front of me now he's
tenth in NFL history in passing
touchdowns
well he's tied for a hundred and fifty
ninth in interceptions okay Ben
Roethlisberger who has one more career
touchdown pass and he does has 96 more
interceptions than he does to him all
right so big bet and he's gonna go down
how about John Elway who I think is
probably the second round quarterback of
all time
he has a hundred and forty-eight more
interceptions than Aaron Rodgers Aaron
Rodgers what he does is so unbelievable
that we go hey if they want to win the
game he's got to throw for about 70% and
he's got to throw three touchdowns and
he's got to make about four jaw-dropping
plays for the Packers to win on a weekly
basis and really he can't make a mistake
or they have no chance and he delivers
and that's why I say he's the greatest
of all time if you noticed there was a
little nugget and what Sims just said
yeah that means that you have Aaron
Rodgers one John Elway two Tom Brady is
he in the top three he's my three over
Peyton I do I think were I like like for
Montana yes I would prop five right now
is Rodgers Elway Brady Manning which one
just kidding Archie and five is always
between to me Brett Favre and Dan Marino
I probably go Dan Marino because he took
care of the ball a little bit better I
think that's what I give him the edge on
but yes that would be my top five and
then he's a great conversational our
Super Bowl thing versus Dan Marino
you're not gonna put anything into that
no you don't care I'm not I'm not gonna
put a whole lot into that I'm not no you
know again I'd rather hang out with
Brett Favre than damn arena yeah I hear
you so you would go Rodgers one Elway
Brady
Manning yeah like I always say Manning's
the man Manning I think like if you took
prime Peyton Manning versus prime Tom
Brady I would say that prime Peyton
Manning is a little bit better than
prime Tom Brady really I do I think at
the pro prime so what was the prime for
both of those guys let's just say I
would let's just go anywhere from like
2003 to 2010 2000 somewhere in there
like hey Peyton I'm gonna give him
clutch a slight edge there in the prime
time but it's not enough to give him the
total edge to me over the consistent
greatness of Brady and then what he's
still doing and like we talked about a
little last week about all we always
talk about Peyton's brains
well what about Brady's brains his
ability to go I need to change my diet
if I want to play longer I need to
change my throwing motion to play a
little I mean if Peyton didn't have that
screwed up motion he can't
to play a few more years - but Brayden
said oh my emotions flawed and I'm not
quite getting out of the most of what I
can do let me revisit how I'm doing this
and now he throws the ball better now
like I've been saying yeah than he did
in 2012 so yeah I don't think we're ever
gonna see Brady have that last year like
Payton did even though Payton won the
Superbowl and it's kind of cloud in the
nineteen interception season yes where
they were he was throwing like a hundred
twenty subjugate interceptions right
nine touchdowns seventeen intercepts yes
so eat of all those five guys who has
the best prime you're talking about
careers yeah so Rodgers Prime lways well
I know that is I mean Rob Rogers is I
have never seen that funny I've never
seen anybody do think John Elway would
say John Elway would I bet she would be
the one guy he'd probably agreed it he'd
probably take away his pride and go you
know what I'm okay with you going
Rodgers over me I understand it really
yeah I mean about Peyton
I don't think Peyton can handle it from
anybody probably couldn't probably
couldn't what about Brady
I think Brady could - I think Brady's
like humble enough and has a less of
enough ego to go man what Aaron ride
like he said it a few years ago like
when Aaron Rodgers is not I turn on the
TV because I just know he's gonna do
stuff that I haven't seen done before
he's [ __ ] amazing he's amazing alright
so between Favre and Rodgers better arm
strength Rodgers arm accuracy Rodgers
mobility Rodgers leadership Favre yeah
what else do you get far mmm that's
about it I don't give him anything else
but I mean we're comparing him we're
comparing him to the what I think the
greatest quarterback of all time so yeah
I mean I'm not gonna give him a degree -
I think he does I know dad what two
weeks ago didn't he tell the story about
he goes I'm sitting here watching Brett
Favre it's the greatest door I've ever
seen and then he went up there two years
ago from training camp he goes damn this
guy's got a stronger arm there Brett
Favre yeah and then it doesn't matter
from that timeout that's just another
conversation we can get into filled with
on Wednesday but any time he would go up
there it would always be Oh Christopher
Christopher I mean Aaron Rodgers and
Friday practice I mean it's unbelievable
I don't know if I saw a wobble baldon
hit the ground he'd thrown no look
passes he's thrown him sidearm 45 yard I
mean he's just that was your best in
person that's what he does and
he is the guy that anytime we have a big
time person come work with the Sims
family at the quarterback he's always
the guy we compare him to like when I
when Dad goes
I mean his arms not like Rogers but it's
close he's got a really strong arm it's
I mean it's not a Roger it's close like
he's always the baseline pretty much
right now you mentioned Jason Garrett I
got hooked I watched like for more
episodes of All or Nothing I didn't
finish it with the Cowboys yeah man the
Jones family is crazy crazy it's called
an everything huh and they're all full
makeup like they all look like they've
just been created like they're Westworld
characters like that like they're always
like and now we're gonna work on our
uniforms dez bryant actually picked all
these out i was like is this what really
happens
did they make you respect jason garrett
more that he has to deal with the jones
family was so two things yeah one this
is how jerry jones runs his football
team he's at a high school football game
and he's taking a hotdog and he goes man
I just I can't this hotdog is incredible
do you think it's the bun and then it
sounds like I don't know it might be the
meat and they're like it and then one of
them goes I think it's because they
wrapped it in tinfoil and he goes we
should get these in the stadium and they
all kind of looked and I was like is
that how the Cowboys run things they
just eat a hotdog and they're like let's
get rid of our caterer we're using these
high school hotdogs like Bertha that
like cooks for the local high school but
Jason Garrett I will be honest I think
it's how they pick players sometimes
there's we got to get him I don't care
how many off field bra major after
Jaylon Smith J Jerry Jones was sitting
there and they showed that clip because
it was like a flashback and they hear
one of the announcers go man I'll tell
you what that's a good player right
there and Jerry goes see he says it's a
good player and I was like no that's not
how you get affirmation like you can't
care about that guy don't care about
Sims and Lefko may be left go but the
thing about Jason Garrett I will be
honest Lombardi calling him the clapper
has weight like I just I don't all of
his speeches are like now fellas you got
to put it behind you you're gonna tackle
the next day because that's who we are
we're gonna write our story yeah and
after like six weeks of hearing it I'm
just not down it's just not that
motivating to me now he's always we are
the best we are like he's I don't
and he's all the sidelines clapping and
I know I know
alright so but I like Jason Garrett and
having met him I get why he's good right
but I don't know well I it was a tough
season for those guys it was a tough
season and also too you know what you're
saying you know again just just so this
is for any fans out there like the
motivation aspect of head coaches it's a
little overrated in all of our eyes
anyways now rich passata got me pumped
up well Rich's got great energy so I
want him to get a head coach but I'll
say this
I think there's respect for a Jason
Garrett I think so you know what I mean
because the biggest thing is yeah okay
he might not be the sexiest and the most
motivated guy in the world but the one
thing I could tell you about Jason
Garrett and a few the guys that even I
know that have been around him and
played for him he's the same guy every
day yes and naturally respected and
everybody knows they're getting there
they're being shot straights like fender
with that right so it's really you know
you're dealing with a very classy
stand-up individual and the players
thinking behind that even though if they
look at some of the conversations or the
speeches like you're saying and they go
yeah I've had better but they can they
can respect the rest of them to still go
out there and want to win four games to
say that when the Satya talked yeah the
whole team was paying attention and I
felt like when Jason Garrett talked
people kind of slouched back whatever of
a basashi up there he's like you need to
love this and the fact that he just went
to go back with Cruden I just know the
Raiders coaches are gonna have those
guys so [ __ ] pumped you're right I
mean even with Gunther at D coordinator
he's got a little pizzazz he's a big
[ __ ] you know definitely Olsen's over
there as the ocean I don't know what he
was he's writing that Gruden he's quiet
but got a great edge about him - I mean
they got they got the right mix they're
gonna have it they're gonna be an edgy
chippy football team you got Marsh on
yeah they got all the veteran players
right I mean he's I could see them
starting off hot
well I and then because they're old and
complaining about that I've been reading
you know there's the fact that they they
think it's underwhelming offseason and
they've filled in voids with older
football players all right well Jon
Gruden has always done that so I don't
know why that's a shock he did it in
Tampa he did in Oakland and he wants to
make sure he gets off to a good start he
doesn't want to trust a first or
second-year guy to make sure that Jon
Gruden era part-2 gets off you know
smelling like roses so he's gonna try
the Jordy Nelson's of the world and
other veterans that he brought in to go
at least I know they're gonna know what
to do when it gets tough early on he's
gonna change the energy like sometimes
you have to change the energy don't you
think just having a guy like Jordy
around Derek Carr could be good for car
yes coupe yeah what do you gain from
that yeah well I think really just with
a guy like Jordy Nelson he just is
another guy that's trusted within the
huddle the offensive side of the ball
he's gonna be I would I would imagine
he's gonna have great dialogue with
Gruden and in car on things he likes to
do route and running wise Gruden's gonna
respect him because he goes you know
you're new once you've been around let
me see if I can formulate some more
place around your skill set and things
you like to do more than Crabtree
because that's really the discussion is
crab cheese younger Crabtree's more
athletic is it better to have Jordy
Nelson around Derek Carr than a Crabtree
from the outside looking in I would say
yes I don't know if Jordy Nelson's is
talented as Crabtree is quite yet of
this he's known of this career in this
career yes Crabtree is definitely more -
he's definitely I'm not sure if it's
definitely like way more than you think
okay I'll say it's I think it's somewhat
close but I would still probably pick
Crabb Crabtree I think you know there's
I don't really know what Crabtree there
a Crabtree to me is a disgruntled
employee like it just when I've seen him
even they're a training camp when I was
with the 49ers a training camps before
that he's always come off to me that way
and I wonder if that's kind of what
happened there and they said we need a
new guy that can be that veteran
leadership presence but also give us
some leadership and not be disgruntled
that he's not getting paid what he said
or whatever else
speaking of disgruntled wide receivers
tío will be giving a Hall of Fame
acceptance speech he'll be at Tennessee
Chattanooga where he went to college
which i think is a great middle finger
to everyone that says he was
dishonouring everyone from his past he's
just doing it on his own terms
yeah I was upset that he's it's gonna be
on at 3:17 in the afternoon I wanted him
to go right up against the Hall of Fame
but I think tio is handing hailing all
of this perfect I do too and I'm really
happy for and I think it's I think it's
actually like I'm with you like it would
have been awesome if you tried to battle
the whole name
but he's doing there the right classy
thing I think fine are you open to the
public free open to the public he's not
trying to step on the toes of any of the
other people that are being ducted into
the Hall of Fame that night he doesn't
want to be there like going up against
Brian Dawkins who he might respect a lot
of right now so I think he's doing it
the right way he's getting it out of the
way and I have his moment he's gonna say
what he wants to say he's giving the
middle finger to the Hall of Fame
yeah but yet not like gonna shove it up
the ass of Randy Moss Brian Urlacher
right there exactly right I think that
was the right man thing to do in my eyes
so I'm all for it actually makes that
Saturday think it's like August 5th or
something like that pretty great yes now
you have like that that hors d'oeuvre of
tío in the afternoon and then at night
all the speeches and what's our Hall of
Fame game that weekend not great
everything it's I think it's Ravens
Raiders no Bears Raiders Bears Raiders
think so
it's one of the induct I mean it's one
of those ears Ravens Bears Ravens Ray
Lewis and Andrew Barker yeah I think I
think you might be right I'll
double-check you know what time it is
what time big offseason whoa big
offseason we're gonna start off first
Sims there's a love in an OTA by the way
programming note we've decided we being
centric and myself because we text too
much we're gonna be doing a whoa big
offseason award show at the end of July
honoring the best woes of this offseason
oh great who had the best like
comparison to a former player who had
the best diet who had the best workout
video we'll do a whoa big offseason whoa
big offseason winner first love at Oh TA
s
Derek Wolfe for the Denver Broncos says
that these are the been the best Oh TA
since he's been in Denver didn't he want
a Super Bowl with those guys he did
interesting he said we're starting to
love each other again it's not every guy
for himself we're like hey if we're
gonna do this we're gonna do it for each
other they love each other sims love
each other again whenever I hear a quote
like that I go what the hell was
happening before yes right yes it makes
that's where I think of like a keep to
leave to leave maybe a TJ word I don't
know but maybe they just lost their way
which can have
and on an NFL football team take me
through that because I was there the
year after the Bucs lost what won the
Super Bowl
so they win in 2002 you're drafted 2003
yeah they come in they they we're gonna
go undefeated
I mean why even show up we're going
undefeated they did talk about the media
and everybody talked about your team
right next year that very much the way
they talked about the Seahawks after
they beat the Broncos where it's not
congratulations on winning it's how many
are we going exactly right
but can anybody beat this team next year
so that alone so that training camp that
OTA must have been filled with love it
was it was love it was it was filled
with love we had to go to Tokyo which
I've talked to you about which throws a
wrench in your schedule that didn't make
things easy on the football team but
yeah it's human nature and I don't care
who you are if you're Jon Gruden Warren
Sapp whatever complacency does set in
when you're being told you're awesome
and your owner says you're awesome and
what do you need and man we're kicking
butt let's just keep doing what we're
doing ya know it always has to be more
it always has to be a better ways like
what you were saying about the Jaguars
but when did you begin to realize that
the team was losing its way yes I say we
lost a few we lost an early is easy
actually can I pull up the schedule just
to make sure exactly here but I'm it's
really I think this it's the Peyton
Manning sheriff game when Warren said it
was 35 14 and they came back with four
minutes left and won the game and beat
us in overtime I would say that's when
the wheels fell off where I was like oh
[ __ ] we might be in trouble that's funny
that you just talked about Peyton's
prime because that was a distinct game I
remember going Peyton's one of the
greatest quarterbacks of all time oh I
mean yes and just Marvin Harrison just
tore you guys up so yeah there's a lot
of stories to go into this all right so
here we go so here's the season I got
the schedule in front of me we beat the
Eagles to open up the link well Gervase
has tipped it to himself called it
ruined me exactly right we lose a tough
one of the Carolina Panthers and next
week we're Julius Peppers blocked I
think three two field goals and an extra
point to win the game well yeah sure all
of it yeah he brought he blocked like a
20-yard field goal to win the game it
was 12 9 and we were gonna kick a field
goal to go into overtime and he blocked
that [ __ ] and ran right
on the field and right into the tunnel
that's incredible that guy is
unbelievable
but then we have a bot where we play the
Falcons we're 31 we win 31 to 10 we're
two and one everything's very good we go
by week and the Colts the next week at
home on Monday night old ABC graphic in
the upper left corner oh and it's it's
35 14 and I can remember Brad Johnson
going over to Gruden and going yeah we
did it
which we got we got the sheriff we
showed the sheriff because Gruden call
it Payton the sheriff at the time that's
already calling the sheriff sheriff's
coming town guys sheriff sheriff's
coming to town sheriff's coming to town
and 3514 well okay yeah they recover an
onside kick all week I'm Peyton Manning
in practice I'm running all the basic
like Peyton Manning Colt plays is that
why you do such a good payment I realize
it's when it started I started to do it
then I had to do a lot of that and
Michael Vick that year cuz Michael Vick
was a lefty of course I wasn't as fast
but they let me run around like a maniac
and that was actually when they were
like damn you're more athletic than we
thought when I get to do that but then
so they come back we ran some plays
during that week in practice that we're
like there go twos and clutch time and
we had some DBS that were well schooled
on this but we had this guy Tim Tim I'm
gonna say it's wodsworth I'm gonna pull
up his name and call him up I can't do
it he was number 31 I'm sorry he's gone
31 on the 2003 bucks and he first bit on
a slant and go up 21 points why would
you everybody why all right so that was
the first touchdown to Marvin Harrison
then like they scored another touchdown
and then the touchdown to score the tie
it up was truly a play that I am gonna
tell you that we ran in practice that
week I'm gonna say 20 times and I hit
the same guy every time and they were
like circled on the card like this is a
guy you're throwing to this is always
who he throws to and the defense was all
over it well it's two minutes left in
the game and he he took the just bring
baited yeah you got the roster there no
I'm still looking at 2003 bucks all
right here we go I just sorted Tim wands
wands ly sorry Tim bonsly have eight
corner out of George and that was about
the end of his career in Tampa good
that pissed Gruden and Mike Tomlin and
Monte Kiffin off to where he was pretty
much run out of town from there but that
was when I went who were in trouble we
won we lost a 49ers game that was the
year Keyshawn and all that happened and
I just we felt our that I could the team
felt you know it's what I want to say
oats or whatever just they were feeling
their oats as I said no sowing reaping
reaping knows another phrase but either
whaling their own yes what were you
trying to say though the team was like
feeling and feeling itself we thought we
were especially with our invincible but
then that Colts game I knew there's a
little panic then we won again and then
we lost again the next week and yeah the
wheels started to fall off feeling ones
oats thank you now feel energetic or
frisky to behave in a vigorous or bold
manner
can you please apologize to me now
treating me like an idiot for making it
so frisky and flirty I've never you know
what I apologize yeah thank you that's
all she should really feel your oats
right but I don't know where I was going
with this story no you were saying that
that that's what it feels I think would
Denver I think when Peyton left the the
wave on Miller still talks about Peyton
Manning he provided structure right all
of those guys and I think Trevor Simeon
wasn't the leader that we kind of
thought he could come yes and when
you're rudderless and you're having a
quarterback controversy and the defense
is still holding it down for two years
after Peyton and then the defense starts
getting injured and you're losing some
defensive line debt and your corners and
you lose TJ war that has been a slow
fallible right now for three years no
yeah and the other thing too just a real
quick to end this conversation other
thing I read into when you read the
quote and I didn't get to it is offense
defense that's where it like maybe he's
talking about like maybe were more of a
team maybe the last few years it was
like a defense we're gonna go to this
club offense yeah I don't know what
you're gonna do this much just the case
keenum cuz everything I'm reading out of
Denver is right that's what you got to
be that's why you're hired
yeah all right now whoa whoa golf season
veteran endorsement yes that's right and
they play the same position Josh McCown
said with Sam
we have the right guy yes great sentence
we have the right guy Jets fans you want
to hear that he's wired the right way he
loves the game he asks the right
questions he's willing to work that's
the foundation you have to have that
Josh wouldn't just say that definitely
now you don't think so I think if it
wasn't the right guy and this guy was a
total idiot he would have never made any
quote he wouldn't have said it you
wouldn't have been able to get a quote
on him on the subject he would have just
stayed in the weeds and been like yeah
you're not gonna hear anything okay for
him to say that yes Josh I don't think
would everybody give the total
professional card unless you were acting
like a professional and it it coincides
was what I've been told from the Jets to
they're excited about what they've got
from saying Donna they think he is a
stud just from the way he handles
himself the way he can handle the
offense the verbage everything from
there and of course they're impressed by
his talent I don't think they've been
blown away by it but still it sounds
like I mean it sounds like everything's
going in the right direction and again I
I think he should be the starter a weak
one if it continues to do that I looked
up the quarterbacks that Josh McCown has
played with that were young when he was
there so I took out his first hit with
the Cardinals when he was the young guy
just what other young quarterbacks he's
been around JaMarcus Russell Andrew
Walter Matt Moore
Jay Cutler Mike Glennon Johnny Manziel
Bryce petty Christian Hackenberg those
last three Manziel petty Hackenberg he
knows what it's like to be around a
young quarterback that maybe isn't wired
the right way maybe doesn't love the
game maybe doesn't ask the right
questions yeah that was the part of that
whole quote that I thought meant the
most asks the right questions because
we've all done jobs some people don't
know what the hell they're doing yes
like when I hear stories like I read an
article mountain Nathaniel Hackett and
Blake bortles and when a sanyo hack at
first got there Blake was like I've
never heard of this stuff before and it
feels like wait you don't even know like
bass stuff like he's had to build Blake
bortles like the bortles that we saw
last year was a Nathaniel hack creation
some guys don't even know what they
don't know know exactly that's the
advantage of Sam Darnell at USC is he's
going to know a little bit more but we
also saw Sam Sam is a lifer yes Sam is a
gamer Sam is obsessed
yes and
some guys like to be the quarterback
some guys are they feel the pressure of
being the quarterback to live up to
everyone's expectations yes and that's
definitely saying yeah it is I think Sam
is I mean you're right we were with them
I think we when he left that day we were
like I get it I get it
right and you could tell you still don't
believe in his arm strength I still see
some issues you still see that he was
scrambling way too much I just have the
speed those are physical issues yeah but
being able to do everything from a
mental perspective and leading the team
and he's gonna be able to do everything
physically - I just said that there was
a few reservations coming out and all
that but yeah I'm it's good to hear and
again the Jets are one of those teams I
look at and just go watch out for
they're kind of sitting in the weeds
they're not saying they're gonna go in
the playoffs but I think they're gonna
mean a pain and a lot of people's ass as
the season goes on that deep well it's
it's a little crazy that they have a
defensive line with al Muhammad
Wilkerson or Sheldon I know these dolls
there Dee is pretty sick though all
right last whoa whoa big offseason it's
a we told you so the reports about ty
God coming in are still so strong we
told you literally the moment that that
what's his name Baker Mayfield to him
see I told you this about Baker maybe
and I get him rubbers name but literally
the night of the draft you said on our
draft coverage ty God is gonna impress
them more than then Baker Mayfield I
know we have a quote from offensive
player and defensive playoff double
whammy
double win the whole team I lose the
whole team right Jarvis Landry about
Tyrod amazing man his leadership his arm
his accuracy and he's ready man he's the
starting quarterback realizes what he
says and then goes and I'm sure that
obviously the decisions up to Hugh and
the offensive staff and stuff like that
but I'm sure they've been highly
impressed with what he's done throw T's
and mini camp that's the first one
defense Christian Curtis is no dummy
either so he's been around he already
said the quarterback that he's played
with Miami write an ad with gates who's
in a good offense he knows the decisions
that are supposed to be made he's a guy
that's fairly new ones and I think would
have a pretty good clue what the
quarterback should do on the play to
play basis Christian
Kirksey on Tyrod yeah he's our guy to
take the field and finally have a
competitive attitude on the offensive
side of the ball lands Reid Gordon all
those guys have a swagger about
themselves in all my years I've never
had that on the offensive side of the
ball yeah so the defense is going holy
crap we have a leader like we have a guy
and then the wide receivers are going
his arm everything he's the man I'm not
hearing anything about our guy Baker
Mayfield no I'm not hearing anything I'm
here and Josh Allen is blown people out
of the water I'm here and Sam Darnell is
the future of the team I'm here in Josh
Rosen is blowing Patrick Peterson away
Lamar Jackson making guys on the
sideline go oh [ __ ] and the story out of
Cleveland Tyra is really good think
about that I know every other Baker the
other thing ever heard about Baker's the
team loves them buddy's a great guy
that's the only thing I've heard but
saying that he got engaged like that to
me is that is a little troubling as
always like to go back to another pic we
didn't hear about your brill peppers and
Cleveland all year last year why because
there was nothing to brag about if the
team drafted a first rounder and there
was any inkling to brag about him the
team does that because it makes them
look better like oh look that guy that
we picked in the first round he's been
amazing like we thought he would yeah so
here is but they didn't talk about your
real peppers why because it was not good
not the Baker fit Mayfield was not good
but I just think again it shows you Tyra
Taylor's got talent this is the best
offensive coordinator he's been with in
his career in Todd Haley so that's gonna
be interesting I would argue it's the
best talent he's had a round of a wide
receiver I mean we know that the
potentials big-time there I know I
didn't put that on the top trio so you
got that you got an old line that's good
running back do you got three running
backs yeah that's all really signed up
so yes it's gonna be interesting there
because this is a team that could be
seven and nine man and be a pain in the
butt and what happens from there but it
just shows you yes right now tie-rod and
what he's doing we knew he's a
phenomenal leader ever since he left
Baltimore really alright that yeah he's
got the physical skills that make guy's
eyes open up and they go wow yeah and
when the defensive guys are saying that
that's to me when it always goes to
another
they don't really know what the hell
defense is supposed to do but they know
that damn they're competing they're not
taking any of our crap they're caching
us for like 20-yard completions every
now that's all they know and they go
that seems good to me and the fact that
they haven't seen that in years tells
you sounds easy right so big offseason
we told you so yeah Tyrod Taylor new
segment yo called Sims and left go on
drugs
oh no likey we're not doing any drugs
but I got three little drug related
stories that are interested okay first
one the drug King Hunter s Thompson a
gonzo journalist that if you ever seen
what was the something in Las Vegas
Dazed not they think what the hell you
totally confuse me you're like the drug
kingpin of a debate and lost in Vegas
what I don't even know anything you just
said
under promises Thompson is no I don't
not off the top of my here and Loathing
in Las Vegas arrest Thompson okay
Thompson was a writer he wrote for
Sports Illustrated write all these books
he has this incredible story the V story
of going to the Kentucky Derby like on
acid and that was his thing he would
experience things in like weird ways and
write about it it's connected to the NFL
apparently he was friends with guess who
which makes me love Jim Irsay
a little bit more if Jim Irsay was that
friends with Hunter s Thompson I really
like it so apparently Hunter s Thompson
this can't imagine doing acid or
anything like that like I I just can't
imagine must be unbelievable so Jim
Irsay was apparently friends with Hunter
Thompson and actually pleaded with Jim
Irsay to draft Ryan Leaf this got
revealed Ryan Leaf posted on Instagram
the letter signed by Hunter s Thompson
it was sent to Ryan Leaf and in it it
said dear James Thompson wrote in
response to your addled request for a
quick thirty million dollar loan to
secure the services of the Manning kid I
have to say no at this time but the leaf
boy is another matter he looks strong
and Manning doesn't or
least not strong enough to handle that
welcome to the NFL business for two
years without a world-class offensive
line how are you fixed it left how are
you fixed at left offensive tackle for
the next few years James means Jim Irsay
think about it you don't want to china
doll back there when the freaks app
comes crashed crashing in which is
amazing
ok let me know if you need some money
for leaf I expect to be very rich when
this debt movie comes out so one I love
the fact that Irsay and Hunter s
Thompson's were apparently friends to
Hunter s Thompson this is back in 99 or
98 was writing on a typewriter and
sending it to people love that yeah
three I love that of all the players to
mention why you protect your quarterback
the freaks app is the first one that
comes to mind Killa who had only been in
the NFL for like a year year and a half
no knowing that what did he come out
yeah he's 94 yes no yeah his last game
in college was Nebraska running it right
up his ass against the Miami Hurricanes
for 95 then yeah I think it's 90 and
that's the one too they won not yet or
95 and they were like 201 4.95 do they
want three out of four years I'll check
it it gave it something like that but no
they won in 94 95 97 I believe they'd be
Peyton Manning in 97 in the Orange Bowl
and that's why they split the national
championship with Michigan and Ryan when
Michigan beat Ryan Leaf and Washington
State I'm corrected 94 95 97 you were
correct yes but it also makes me laugh
and go men that was a legitimate debate
Ryan Leaf and and Peyton Manning look
Durant
Odin was a legitimate debate right
LeBron Carmelo was a legitimate debate
yeah rg3 Andrew Luck was a legitimate
debate yeah but it just hunter s
Thompson though it was a funny story it
is hilarious and I can still remember at
that time you know cuz I was I was
making my way into college football and
I have is I mean I was
I love Peyton Manning I mean he was the
reason I was gonna commit it to
Tennessee right cuz I was like ah he's a
man this is any course had a similar
life to me cuz he grew up under his dad
just like I did and I just said wow this
is really cool somebody like me is
making it and I'm you know I'm gonna
make it to tell me the truth did you
think it Ryan Leaf was gonna be a good
quarterback oh I did I definitely did I
did and everything he could've been
better than they
I did I did I thought I was like Moo he
might be better than Peyton I don't know
Peyton was still my favorite and the guy
I wanted because at the time - there was
Peyton haters of the world and I was
like what like I'm you been watching
college football the last year there's a
lot of like all he does is throw at ten
yards - peerless price and then he runs
for a vent in tears I don't want to be
like what are you are you kidding me I
mean I could show you like bombs all
over the field from Peyton Manning he
was awesome but I did recognize Leestown
leaf like our Manhunter s tops it was a
it was a big thick guy who was probably
even faster than Peyton Manning and had
a stronger arm and I just know that just
people in football at that time when
they would tell me about Ryan Leaf
they'd be a clue it's pretty special in
person he can really throw it you know I
remember my dad seeing him in person and
going like man he can really let it go
but that's where meeting people comes
into play - yeah I mean that's what's
our biggest you know downfall in this
business is we don't have to meet some
of these guys yeah and yeah I think
Peyton Manning from the most part of
every story I've ever heard just knocked
people's socks off when they met him and
got him on a chalkboard and Ryan Leaf I
think was like some people were like oh
we like him he's cool he's got a little
edge about it where other were like he's
a buffoon I don't think he's got a clue
yeah I just thought it was funny that
the Tennessee like scouting director was
like oh it was super easy we wanted
Mariota never even thought about Winston
I'm like so easy to say after the fact
that was another good one and I don't
know maybe cheesy to say it's so easy to
pick Mariota you mean the guy that threw
13 touchdowns and 16 interceptions last
year huh you're gonna bow memes we made
the right pick those really is that yeah
that's you know people don't list like
pay attention we just go he's Mariota
and they went to the playoffs and he won
a Heisman five years ago so it must have
been good no 13 touchdowns 16
interception team Oh 15 quarterback
rating of 79 so there we go I mean oh
definitely Mariota yeah I mean I
understand Jameis is a buffoon an idiot
and I don't like him for what he's doing
about the field but like yes that's a
[ __ ] comment by Tennessee Scout I
just like there yeah we've definitely
picked the right one he throws more
interceptions and touchdowns yes you're
gonna break the tape next up on Sims and
let go on drugs
if you snitch I snitch we snitch the NFL
peds niching NFL apparently your your
other guy apparently found out the NFL
will reduce suspensions by up to 50%
if a player snitches on another play
Lane Johns and the Eagles came out and
said no snitching that's all he tweeted
no snitching have you ever heard of this
before I did not when I read this I was
like whoa I did not know this is a rule
no idea all right so here's my thing
yeah you are a very very strict anti PE
D guy yeah if you did steroids get out
of Sims as fatty [ __ ] hate you right
how do you feel about a PE d user that
also snitches oh gosh you're just the
near the lowest form of life do you
think I mean do you just get blackballed
immediately it's its secret first of all
most people don't maybe there's a few
people that like the the cheaters they
cheat together and it's a very small
crew okay and they roll together and you
don't know why they roll together until
one of them gets caught cheating you
know uh that makes sense why those three
guys with those gigantic chests or hang
out together one of your teams well I
there was a few that were in it you know
yeah I'd certainly crossed my mind to
yes and tan that's a low-life crew I
know so that that rule is shocking but I
guess it's the appropriate rule for the
NFL but yes it's a very it's nobody
wants to be known as the cheater in the
locker room so nobody really knows
always until you get busted and then
yeah so I never asked you this yeah have
you ever been on a team where a guy get
busted for peds you know I don't think I
ever was just I'm trying to real close
curious how the team would like to act
around them from now on if they'd be a
pariah if you'd like not want to be seen
in the gym you know everybody's cool but
I feel like when you're that guy you're
gonna have people are gonna make
comments behind your back in the locker
room like every now and then I'm sure I
can't I'm just trying to real quickly
Tampa we did not have anybody and then
Tennessee definitely no and Denver I
don't think we had anybody there either
you know in Tampa did we have a guy or
two that I was like it's questionable
but that's about it
now the the thing that I realized is if
you see a guy with a 2-game PE d
suspension he's also a snitch like now
we know it's gonna it's definitely
they're all familiar because it's got
two other guys from his team just came
out so it's definitely you yes yes
you're right if you see a two game
because two game Peters don't happen you
could see really even when you're
supposed to be suspended for street
drugs like when you see that cut down at
times
that's that because of snitching that's
literally because there must have been
some other disagreement like he didn't
fail another drug test maybe he missed
the piss test or something like that
that's why he's got cut down the two but
yeah for PE D use if you got cut down to
four to two you're right that's about
the only thing that would get it to cut
down too I just think I think of it like
when I'm in an interrogation room with a
police officer and he's like now
listening we've got you for peds if you
give up that old wide receiver we think
we've got him I'm gonna give him up like
no you just got to take your lumps man
because then you're gonna be there's no
magic pill
okay let's I saw Ron wearing a hat
what was it there's no magic pill he
wore one during the playoffs what if he
wanted to gain money that he's wearing
that by me there's no magic pill all
right last one for Simms and left go on
drugs
eggwin was was that man
LeSean McCoy posted a picture on
Instagram of him and Frank Gore working
out together and he said that you know
Frank Gore
he's been my role model for a very long
time drugs playing into this and gore
replied by saying that LeSean McCoy is
the best running back in the NFL he said
the best run back of the NFL shady McCoy
10 years in still doing it is Frank Gore
on drugs
no he's not
Frankie's awesome dude he's one of the
best dudes in football and so is LaShawn
and I mean best running back now I mean
yes I come on it's it's a stroke vest
okay they're working out together if we
get it okay it's all cool it's it's
understandable there's so much to
respect there again I don't think it is
interesting because I think he's the
second leading active rusher in the NFL
right now
hein Franco yes really in 10,000 yards
rushing and I look at LeSean McCoy and
go hall-of-famer
and then I go Frank Gore and I go I'm
not sure I don't think it's all a favor
I think he's gonna be in that
conversation when all sudden done
because I don't I think he's got still
two three years left of of of good play
so he's gonna add another thought he's
gonna have three more thousand yards
rushing he's gonna add another two
thousand receiving when all Sunda I
think when he gets up there and he gets
a retired we're gonna go damn he's one
of the best running backs we ever saw he
did it consistently in a certain level
for a long time pass game and run games
my question is Frank Gore on drugs no no
my big question is can you tell the
story of the NFL without LeSean McCoy
and I think you can you probably can I
will say this he's had two great snow
games I look back at his tenure with the
Eagles and I wish I appreciated it more
right because I will say he's in my top
five running backs all-time in terms of
entertaining running backs to watch yes
he's up there with the Barry Sanders of
the world in terms of stopping on a dime
I think it stats would have been better
to of Andy Reid wasn't his coach
wherever in the road all the time yeah
oh I mean and then he had the one year
that one year with Chip Kelly when it
was him and Jeremy Maclin and DeSean
Jackson with Vick I think that was
actually the end of Andy Reid that year
was incredible the Shawn McCoy was
amazing your friend of Adrian Peterson
still playing so he would be yeah so
lashauwn's got ten thousand ninety two
career rushing yards right now right
ten thousand career 92 rushing yards
it's got a lot more time he does so I
mean if he just gets a thousand if he
gets a thousand yards this year you know
a little over a thousand he's gonna be
top 20 all-time career Russian yes
because two thousand and then if he I
mean if you got two thousand he's gonna
be in the top 15 basically okay right so
what about 3,000 because the 3,000
daddy's gonna be top ten okay he's gonna
be he's gonna be in the the Jim Brown
ended up with 12,000 312 and he's number
10 all-time so if he gets the 13,000
he's gonna jump Tony Tony Dorsett who's
also in the 12,000 let's Frank we're at
right now Frank Gore is number five
all-time with 14,000 26 and how far is
he behind number three
Curtis he's gonna pass Curtis Martin
maybe in the first game he's 75 yards
behind Wow right so he's number two
number wellhe's and he'll become number
four sorry I'm wrong
Barry Sanders is three so a Frank Gore
has over 1200 yards this year he's gonna
pass Barry Sanders - right how do you
not put him in then you tell the story
of Frank Gore though just to argue that
what can you tell the NFL story but that
frankly yes okay there did this yeah
Frank Gore to me is one of those amazing
stories of resilience that I feel like
the NFL would want to celebrate like
three ACL tears in college
the Miami running back that they all
said was the best but you never got to
see behind Willis McGahee and Clinton
Portis and all inage Davenport and all
those guys yeah I like Nagi a lot yes
but Frank Gore's story and just being so
consistent but yeah you could totally
tell the story the NFL without Frank
Gore totally I know and I'm trying to uh
but he's still great and like I like him
and if I met it might be like full term
for the old Foom but I wanted to ask you
this yeah pull up the teams right who
are the top five running backs in the
NFL right now okay is LeSean McCoy in
there let's pull up the team I want to
look guys do this at home too
I want to look at one thing first
okay I'm gonna pull up the team okay but
what are you looking up I just wanted to
see what LeSean McCoy where he was
career all-purpose yards to because I
think that's really where you know of
course you know what's crazy is number
eight all-time career all-purpose yards
yeah
Darren Sproles number eight all-time yes
let's does that include
punting and kicking us I don't that time
I know Frank Gore's 12 all the time when
it comes to that he's 17 thousand seven
hundred and five let's see where the
hell is he all right so he's farther
down here than I thought
it's not as many passing yards ace he's
got thirteen thousand four hundred and
seventy-one career LeSean McCoy so he's
got a little more work to do than I
thought he did you thought he was
probably like the 17 I'm sorry Bobby
around like 15 somewhere in that range
I thought we also had Darren Sproles ons
team a little bit yeah you did alright
so top five running backs right now
let's just let's just put the names out
there that we know we're gonna make the
cut levy ons making the cut
correct collect correct todd gurley
correct no one on New England I'm gonna
put LaShawn on a piece of paper we'll
get back to it
anyone in Miami no jets no levy on no
one on Baltimore Joe mix-ins not in this
conversation I think anyone in Cleveland
I'll put four net down I don't know if
he's gonna make it
Ezekiel Ali is definitely in the top
five okay so we have three definites
already yeah
what about any in Kansas City mm-hmm I
know
Kareem hunt is certainly he's in the
Milken Gordon and next conversation
there you're not gonna do Marshawn Lynch
no one on Denver know no one on the
Eagles you already said seek no one on
Washington we can't put sake one in yet
Minnesota Dalvin cook Detroit no Jordan
Howard or anybody I haven't gotten to
them guys all right so I'll put Jordan
Howard down five Kimora is definitely on
the piece of paper yeah
no one on Carolina I think McCaffrey's
there yet Atlanta you have Freeman Tampa
Bay no Rams we already said Gurley
Seattle no Arizona David Johnson and
then I don't think you're gonna put
Jerick McKinnon alright just end it okay
who do you got all right all right so so
who you have what six there yeah to me
read your final six in no order yeah or
is that seven it's seven actually okay
all right but levian girly floor net
Ezekiel a bit Freeman David Johnson and
I did right LeSean okay I just want to
make sure I'm not missing anybody else
there but I don't think so
okay bright away oh my gosh is this
let's start off which two will you
eliminate Josh damn so again he said
levy on girly Zeke LaShawn Burnett I'm
Freeman Jean out right now
you are first elimination I'm gonna take
him out I don't yeah maybe the reasoning
I just because it's your 10 and I don't
think he's in the class of these other
guys right now okay so the Shawn is out
so you have the the two that I feel like
are on the outside looking in that are
battling for the fifth spot is Devonta
Freeman and Leonard fournette yeah do
you agree with that I do and you just
Eva Johnson is in the top five agreed
even if he's coming off injury I think
the best runningback show no Kimora I'm
not gonna put Kimora there yet
nope I'm not he's on the edge and I'm
not gonna put fournette there yet either
I'm gonna cancel him out for now as much
as you know I love Leonard for nine
point nine yards forget just totally
[ __ ] because he had ten guys in the
box every play we all know it and that's
just the way it was and I mean they're
talking about we don't want to kill them
have you read of course try to have to
kill them this year because we almost
killed them last year because we ran
them into so many boxes where we didn't
have enough people to block the [ __ ]
people are gonna knock his head off but
he said want a Freeman make sure tough
eye Devonta Freeman would be nine number
five he would be my number Devante yes
I'm going girly as the number one
running back in football right now Wow
yeah I know I would go girly one I think
hmm
I'm gonna go Ezekiel Elliott - I love
Ezekiel Elliott now I know it's not the
most perfect year last year I think
those we're gonna see a different
monster this year and I just think I
think that watching the all-or-nothing
with the Dallas Cowboys you don't
realize the struggles that Zeke was
going through with traveling all the
time not being able to go to a team
until Wednesday said missing six games
that hanging over him the whole year I
mean what he did to get in that position
I'm not gonna condone it yes it's awful
right but in terms of the you know the
impact it had from a football
perspective oh I thought the whole time
I was watching on seats could have a big
year yes you still averaged four yards a
carry
so Zeke is - so would you have Olevia
how far is levian falling I know it's
right Mike you're gonna fight for a
salary or what no I'm actually thinking
about what I'd need to do maybe maybe
he's not David Johnson's right there
with these guys - he's right in this
conversation Fontes you're five Devante
is my five for sure and girlies my one
for sure
okay that's right now you're going Zeke
- and then are you gonna have levy on
the-- or David Johnson I want to go
David just because I know he's younger
and he has less wear and tear and I am
Wow yeah you're gonna make levy on four
I am I would have gone now that I've
kind of heard it I think I would
actually gone levy on one girly to David
Johnson three Zeke four Freeman five
yeah my reasoning is I feel like David
Johnson and levy on are bigger weapons
in the passing game and Zeke yeah Zeke
can still catch the ball yeah and I know
he has the high level speed but I feel
like levy on and David Johnson are on
another level like I tell me I know that
you think I'm probably wrong now I think
Gurley levy on and David Johnson when I
look at them are physically bigger than
Zeke I feel like they have better hands
than Zeke and they're more athletic than
Zeke but I don't think they have his
straight-line speed I don't think so I
don't think they're bigger I think
zeeky zeeky only it's thicker he's a
like a he's a damn cinderblock okay 230
pounds
and he's like he has to watch his weight
to make sure he doesn't go both unless
you're kind of threw me off a little bit
then in terms of just oh remember he got
chubby last year that's what we were
compatible at earlier I'm thinking about
chubby Zeke yeah I admit you know I mean
that's where the two three four all
right so I'll say this this is where I
get into this conversation and I think
this is a really good conversation I'm
glad you actually brought this up Gurley
to me is the most dangerous running back
in the sport right now any play he could
any play it doesn't matter and he had 64
receptions and led the rams last year in
receptions 788 yards 12 point 3 yards
per carry
he can be an 80 yard screen pass it
could be a 60 yard run up the middle so
that's where I look at him and that
offense and just go that is very I mean
that he's an extremely talented guy with
big-time home-run-hitting speed so I
think that's why I give him the edge
there man you got to be really thinking
about 2 3 4 5 though but I forgot I mean
2 3 4 I still think I would go zekiel
David Johnson Le'Veon Bell I know that's
really her prize at Levien's 4th that's
the best prize ever the biggest thing
for me but levian is he's awesome he
does have wear and tear and I just don't
think he's as explosive as the two I've
said in front of him he his patience and
at the line amazing has been captivating
but I do agree with you that sometimes
you want him to just hit it yeah and
then the last year when he hit it it
wasn't as impactful as when he used to
hit
he's not gonna go for 50-yard touchdown
that's not he's not capable of that
David Johnson will he he will I do
yeah I think David Johnson I mean I know
Johnson me as young as young levy on
bail without the knee injury that he got
against perfect right so I just look
that's why I do it again I don't want to
come off here as I'm knocking lovely on
bail because I think he is awesome yes
you and I know we marvel at watching him
and when I saw him play in person
standing on the sidelines against the
Green Bay Packers last year man is he
fun to watch and made a lot like LeSean
McCoy the ability to stop and start and
you know he can bounce off tackles
there's more physical than people give
him credit like I owe the reason that I
love levian and him and David Johnson
both to this Curley doesn't do this they
both get lined up at wide receiver
yes and I don't see that out of Zeke or
Gurley they'll get sent out there but
it's consistent with levian and David is
there it's it's a huge part of their
offense I mean it is so again Dadar Todd
Gurley is a guy that I think could do
that but that's just not the way they do
McVeigh runs his offense you know we've
never seen Kyle do that really either
right that's just not what their normal
is where Haley and Arizona which was
really old another time yeah Bruce
Arians that they believed in that so
yeah even splitting that guy so I'm not
I'm trying not to dock players for
things they're not asked to do like
Ezekiel Ali I'm pretty confident he
could catch the ball more than he does
yes susyq measured in the combine at
6-foot 225 right David Johnson was 6 1
to 24 okay
levy on it's hard because his combined
weight was like 240 yes right I don't
know what it is Zeke is insanely thick
insanely thick pcs he's a hundred meter
sprint champ in Missouri I mean he's
he's just I always think of things like
this remember the 80 yard screen man
Pittsburgh it's Ryan shazier chasing
after I'm Sean Davis Jason and they went
out of the frame and they can't catch
him so he's got a special burst that's
interesting alright I like your top five
all right
all right you want to play a little
reddit game now we can put it on social
and I can get [ __ ] on the rest of the
week it's great you've learned my place
yes
is gonna be on social Latvian might see
this alright so I want to say that it's
been really fun to check out the reddit
for Simms and left Quahog things we
never talked about Julian Edelman - oh
let's talk about Julian I just I just
thought it was fascinating that again I
mean not fascinating but the fact that
he's not challenging the steroids the
fact he's just challenging the process
the paperwork exactly so that just tells
everybody out there and just for all the
people that were sending me hate crap
about Julian Edelman is perfect no he's
not and he's basically with his defense
admitted that he took something illegal
and he just wanted to find a loophole in
the process of what happened so again
this substance they found that I don't
think they still know it what it is
but it has a similar chemical
composition to a Natur
performance-enhancing drugs and that's
what it is and that's why he's busted
researched on him they just found it
they just found it
alright so I've been loving the reddit
and what they've done I mentioned the
fantasy football earlier but I was on
reddit and I saw this question from
crazy cause mm and it's the first player
that comes to mind when you think of a
certain team what I want to start doing
it Sims and Lefko is what I love about
reddit they always ask these open-ended
questions and everyone kind of fills in
the responses I like to help tackle the
reddit question so what I would ask to
everybody out there is if you see a
reddit question that we do on this show
throw it in the thread throw it in there
go hey guys Sims and Lefko actually
talked about it put the YouTube clip
because I'd like to be one of the only
mainstream shows that actively engages
with the reddit community I think people
are afraid of reddit I'm not I think
smart people are on reddit I mean some
people don't read it or smarter the guys
I see on television you better read it
for a long time
it's the newspaper of the Internet's so
first player that comes to mind so
here's how I want to play this game cool
game I like it this is not the best
player this is the first fire right so I
say we go back and forth with a team and
we see what we say or I say a team I'm
gonna say a team pause think of a guy
and then say at the same time okay okay
so first one I'm gonna go Baltimore
Ravens thought of it first one Joe
Flacco Ray Louis Joe by all time yeah
player not just on me I go modern times
Ray Lewis sorry no you first look you
thought was just like I was thinking
modern players I was thinking guys on
the right so we can open it up to any
anybody like just that team okay sorry
so guys play this at home too so I'll
say the team so Baltimore Ravens and we
already loose okay let's do Houston
Texans JJ Watt warren moon he I just
think of Houston I know when you said
Houston I was thinking more and mood at
first well you said Texans and that's
why I had a pause and I just think of JJ
y JJ Watt yeah well he will be the best
text of all time yes he will he will
okay that was an easy one okay Houston
Oilers oh I'm with you yeah Jacksonville
Jaguars David Gerard gosh do you have
come on you didn't think no I took me a
second Mark Brunell is really the first
actually thought a Blake bortles first
that's the first one it was when my bike
bortles won in my mind first there's
this when I hear Jacksonville I think of
like berths
how much are you are you still getting
Blake bortles stuff yeah yeah sorry I'll
be quicker here no that was good I
should wait more until you have one okay
Dallas Cowboys I don't know why I
thought of this guy who do you think
cause you got one yes ready tour since
we were talking before the show yes and
I love Troy Troy is one of my favorite
Cowboys one of my favorite quarterbacks
ever I have no idea I just thought of
Tony Dorsett I don't know either
there's Roger stone that's a tough one
though that may be so many they have
some stars that are they're all worthy
if I were to like spend time and like
really think because I like playing the
first one that comes to your mind but
maybe Michael Irvin or Leon let someone
from like Larry Alex I'm from that era
that was mighty on Roger Staubach
Dorsett Edie
too tall Jones Drew Pearson I mean it's
unbelievable Randy white back in the day
they have so many names
I was thinking door seconds we're
talking Senate but that is I saw a
question on reddit to which was why when
we talk about the greatest running backs
of all time is Emmett never said yeah I
think it's to me it's a little bit like
Joe Montana where I never say Joe
Montana zone the grace not to say that
they're not one of the all-time greats
but that was the greatest offensive line
in history I think in that era I don't
think any of us would argue that Barry
Sanders was not the
running back in that era and if Barry
Sanders had the line that Emmitt Smith
had in Dallas then we the all-time
leading rusher would be somebody
different all right
New England Patriots I'm Brady Drew
Bledsoe was the first thing that is
[ __ ] lyin I thought of the old Patriot
logo on my gozar Brady or Belichick
almost right away
yeah I'm playing a different game I'm
playing like what face pops up yeah
you're thinking I would like to do a
modern day right now but this is still
fun
go ahead all right well how about you do
modern days and I'll do whatever comes
to my head I have a cramp oh my god in
your hamstring yes how is that possible
it's in my ass now yeah yep that's how
much of an athlete it's hip flexor
problems probably I got a dual cars um
I'm gonna stand now you should be
embarrassed
why did you don't get cramps not what
I'm doing podcast I don't know how that
happened Godley Miami Dolphins damn dan
Marino yeah he's a dolphin yes there was
anyone even close
Don Shula is the remember the other guy
that I know I'm not trying to think of
coaches much but Don Shula would be in
that at least he was the other guy that
comes to my mind alike I need you to say
teams because I'm thinking about it now
as I'm looking at ya I know you're and
then you're mad at me that I'm not as
quick as you and you've already seen the
team that this is hilarious okay here we
go yeah you do them now New York Jets
okay there we go
Buffalo Bills Oh Jay Simpson hmm I
thought about OJ first I thought about
peerless price til you ready yes here we
go big time a lot of ones to pick for
here Pittsburgh Steelers one to Terry
Bradshaw ooh first thing I actually
thought about was plain wrong I'll give
you one two threes I know because it's
modern that's I ever that's why I was
like that's where I was saying that
we're gonna go through all the teams you
want me just beep let's just keep going
all right oh this is a tough one all
right Cincinnati Bengals okay about it
okay on three one two three
TJ Morris iesson yes sir grandpa I grew
up around new teachers bent on I'm not
gonna lie I thought of Jon Kitna and
then I thought of Oh Josie Ellen Brown
on three one two three Isaiah that was
really disappointing what a loser all
right we did Jacksonville earlier the
history I'm just like for Gurjit a ting
Tennessee Titans one two three Steve
McNair yes okay Indianapolis Colts one
two three Peyton Manning Johnny Unitas
oh yeah he's mine went to Payton first
day I'm like all right Kansas City
Chiefs mmm Patrick look there's Thomas I
go Derek Thomas you're Len Dawson
they're San Diego Chargers one two three
Dan Fouts yes hi Oakland Raiders shut up
one two three Oakland Raiders can Ken
Stabler damn Denver Broncos one two
three John Elway I thought if al Wilson
goes one two three
Reggie White I thought of do Staley what
is wrong with you go back to your
segment on drugs okay I think you're on
drugs right now we did the Washington
red snow we do now we did Dallas
Washington Redskins okay one two three
I thought a monk I thought of the
quarterback that one Joe Theismann no
Mark Griffin no all right we'll keep it
going New York Giants one two three
Lawrence Taylor thank you wow man all
right so you're not even Phil so we
should no no I'm
you used to be modern-day but this is
what happens the person that asks the
question thinks of history the person
that is being asked just thinks of yeah
because you don't have the time the time
okay Minnesota Vikings I thought of John
Randall mmm Fran Tarkenton nice then we
got the Detroit Lions I'm gonna think of
Barry Sanders I guess I my mind went to
Calvin Johnson actually that staffer
Green Bay Packers
Aaron Rodgers you're in my head all the
time mark Chmura honey you're such a
jerk Chicago Bears dick Mike Singletary
who do you think's more Chicago Bears I
think Ditka yes I mean if they embraced
him more yeah I guess New Orleans Saints
I thought of Jeff George I don't know
why I actually just thought of Ditka
when you said that first no drew Brees
would still be my second thought there
Carolina Panthers
I thought of moosie Mohammad I went dick
Dell home actually and it should be Cam
Newton all the way he's the best player
in their franchise history or Steve
Smith that's who we should be really
thinking of Atlanta Falcons or who's the
first guy that comes to your head Jesse
Tuggle I think Michael Vick came to my
adverse sure that's still I'm still like
traumatized by him it's third no team
can we sack this [ __ ] guy oh there he
goes he got 19 holy [ __ ] how did he get
19 yards on that we dropped eight guys
in the coverage and they were all
looking at him that's like what me and
Cadillac Williams used to sit there and
do like when we played him because it
was unreal yeah but I feel like the Bucs
always beat we beat them but it was
still unreal we had the best defense in
football our defense was still scared
it's always tore up the Panthers but the
Bucs would always keep him contained
they did for the most part but it was
pretty fascinating I like when you read
the team's okay keep it going
Tampa Bay Buccaneers I love John Gurdon
I thought of Brad Johnson for big Brad
it's got to be rude in Sapp my hip mine
goes right there to Gruden Sapp right
off the bat all right we're getting the
last glass division here Los Angeles
Rams Rams
I think of Torry Holt I am I don't even
know I honestly did not have a thought
that went into my head I wouldn't like
old school for a second who Deacon Jones
they're like man I gosh are you gonna
quarter I want Jim Everett for a second
who was the Rams best player in history
let's see if they have any Hall of
Famers well they definitely do they have
Orlando pays I guess yeah I mean Kurt
Warner martial arts is hard when you see
Los Angeles I don't think of them right
away
George Allen is in the Hall of Fame
there coach of course you're gonna make
me lunch of Lausanne Los Angeles throws
me off though but really should be like
Marshall Faulk or well know what about
their defensive pass rushers Jackie
Youngblood Joe Deacon Jones yeah yeah
Jackie young about played with a broken
leg Seattle Seahawks I thought or
Russell Wilson yeah I do too Richard
Sherman man I mean it's it's definitely
modern-day guys I feel like more than
anything Arizona Cardinals
I went Larry Fitzgerald not letting
anything settle and trying to keep going
I went Larry Fitzgerald Arizona he's the
best player I think in their franchise
history Arizona I think of oh man Jake
Plummer if I really like the one that
matters to me the most Jake Plummer
I know it's hard when you think about
when I grew up I don't know and then the
last one is the San Francisco 49ers
which tonight of Joe Mont I did too
right oh yeah I think of him over the
Jerry Rice which would be the next guy
in my mind there yeah but what were you
know about your era of Arizona Cardinals
like I thought like my era growing up
Arizona it was like one of those teams
that was never in the playoffs Oh kind
of a pain in the butt and never had that
star player ever ever I mean as I as I
got older Aeneas Williams became they
were always the team that got their ass
kicked in the NFC East and everyone
penciled them in for six wins a year and
then plumber came in with these like
comebacks and we were like man this team
is annoying yeah they were even a little
annoying in my dad's day I feel like
that franchise really turned around
after Jerry Maguire had helped it out oh
no you think so
yeah I might have made it a little more
popular a little cooler a little cooler
yeah yeah this game goes two ways either
turns a modern day or old school their
modern day old school but what happens
is you want to impress people with cool
names and not regurgitation like what
because it what you did with like Jake
Plummer that was cool one right yeah I
thought about it for a while exactly
cool but it's just funny that that's the
reason why there's like 17 the last
twenty two MVPs have been quarterbacks
it's the first guy you think it is it's
always a quarter like Jerry Rice like he
should be right away I know I know but
unfortunately he's on a team with a
quarterback
four Super Bowl rings and two Super Bowl
MVPs yeah three Super Bowl anything it
was cool yeah it was cool he was cool
yeah guys love you so much thank you as
always
we will be back home Wednesday we will
have the big [ __ ] big Phil in here
not sure else we're gonna go yeah a lot
of big stuff happening you're going on
vacation next week I am as well we're
gonna figure out something though to
make sure you guys get your podcast so
we'll have something planned as always
hit us up on Sims and left go on all
social at Sims and left go get involved
in the reddit it's a lot of fun and also
throw our stuff into that chain and
enjoy your summer guys your whoa whoa
for Sims peace out homey Cedric says
good evening and the lef koe man says
holla holla holla holla holla we'll talk
to you guys later
be well